President Vladimir zielinski inspecting
what he hopes will make a difference in
the skies above Ukraine Dutch prime
minister Mark Ruta announcing the
long-awaited first donation of F-16
fighter jets for the exactly I cannot
give you but we are working from the
fact that as this moment we still have
42 in stock here it was then this short
hop to Denmark for the announcement of
19 more f-16s zelenski finally getting a
feel for a jet he has long pleaded for
more than 70 people from Ukraine is now
on the ground here in in
preparing for for training
Ottawa is helping with training and
Logistics even though Canada doesn't
have f-16s the Jets were designed in the
1970s a similar age to the Soviet era
Plains Ukraine currently owns the f-16s
however have been modernized one of the
big benefits that f-16s are going to
give Ukraine is that the other weapons
that have been provided will be able to
be used much more effectively Ukraine
has said the first f-16s won't be in
operation until next year we understand
the number of jets we can use in the
future nearest or or not it depends on
the situation and on the experience of
our Pilots getting those Pilots Airborne
is one thing turning them into Aces is
another this is the the kind of
balancing act that Ukraine has had to do
throughout this conflict zelenski is
hoping more countries will follow and is
already pushing for donations of
Sweden's Gripen fighter jets too Redmond
Shannon Global News London